eight months ago they were dispatching
these ambulances to help out with the
pandemic in new york
now it's on their own doorstep in north
dakota case numbers are rising faster
than anywhere in the u.s
we're seeing all of the wings and the
nursing staff and the doctors just
swamped like they're stretched so thin
and they're working around the clock
with all of these different
uh you know covert positive patients
this is one of those hospitals in
jamestown almost at capacity
it activated its surge plan last week
and in a rural hospital
patients are often friends and neighbors
i think everyone here
has had to take care of a few people
that they've had you know that they've
known and
didn't have the greatest outcome neither
especially
when you don't see their family members
in the store it's almost hard to
to look them in the eye you know you you
and your heart
believe you did everything you could but
um it's uh
it's hard so um that's all i got
they're all feeling the strain exhausted
at times overwhelmed
just the little things like sitting with
them and holding their hand and
that's hard
lynn was admitted on friday you know you
change your life
to the isolation more you're doing all
this stuff
and then all of a sudden you've got it
and it's like
where did i get it from for so long
it didn't touch us and it's getting
scary
and the death rate is going up
they always said social distancing would
be easy in the wide open of america's
prairies but
in places like jamestown the jokes
wearing thin
the coronavirus mortality rate in north
dakota is now the highest
not just in the u.s but in the world and
the governor has only just
issued a mandate to wear masks even now
some think that's wrong is this going to
be broadcast in north dakota
and i think it stinks in the quilting
shop
trish and bev express what many here
think
if you could convince me that living my
life any different would help
maybe i'd listen but you know it seems
to me we're
living our lives the way we are numbers
are going up any
all across the nation anyway so i
haven't really seen enough evidence yet
that convinces me that i should stay
home and twiddle my thumbs and
and weep over it but that's harsh that's
not dakota harsh
what will be harsh doctors say is the
coming winter family gatherings at
thanksgiving and christmas
making things worse and the peak here
still to come
greg milam sky news north dakota